สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้
วัน
พฤหัสบดีค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 6 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกรกฎาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 5 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกรกฎาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้
วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
7 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกรกฎาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลาเที่ยง
กี่นาที
เที่ยง 36 นาทีค่ะ
ก็เป็นเวลากลางวัน
เป็นตอนกลางวัน
ครูฟ้าน่าจะตื่น 100% แล้ว
แต่ดูจากหน้านี่เขาจะตื่นแล้ว
ครูฟ้าตื่นแล้วหรอคะทำไมครูหญิงตื่นหรือ
ยังดูหน้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยเหมือนครูฟ้าตื่น
ประมาณ 2%
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะครูฟ้า
2% ครูฟ้าจะตื่น 2
20% ครูฟ้าจะตื่น
200%
ก็ไม่เป็นไรครูฟ้าจะตื่นน้อยตื่นมากครู
หญิงก็จะมีเกมมาเล่นกับครูฝ่า
มีคำถามมาถามครูฟ้าค่ะ
ฮัลโหลครูฟ้าเกม
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้ไม่ได้ยินครูฟ้าเลยอ่ะ
ครูหญิงจะมีคำถามมาถามครูฟ้าค่ะครูฟ้าจะ
ตื่นหรือว่าครูฟ้าจะหลับถ้าครูฟ้าหลับครู
ฟ้าจะได้ตื่นเพราะครูฟ้า
นี่คือครูฟ้าใช่ไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องคิด
แต่ครู
คำถามเกี่ยวกับร่างกายค่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ยเคย
เล่นไปแล้ว 1 ครั้งจำได้ไหมเนี่ยว่าเรามี
ปอดกี่ข้างมีฟันกี่ซี่เอาอวัยวะที่ไหน
ใหญ่ที่สุดชิ้นไหนหนักที่สุดแล้วก็ครูฟ้า
เนี่ยเก่งมากผู้หญิงจำได้ว่าข้อ 1 ก็ถูก
ข้อ 2 ก็ถูกข้อ 3 ก็ถูกข้อ 4 ก็ถูกเก่ง
มากผู้หญิงเนี่ยมีมาถามอีกค่ะ
ไหนคะ
ถามเกี่ยวกับอันนี้ครูฟ้าใช่ไหมคะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
อันนี้ทุกคนไงเนี่ยในร่างกายของเราเนี่ย
ก็จะมีกระดูกใช่ไหมคะกระดูกเขาบอกว่าเวลา
ที่เราเนี่ยอันนี้คุณแม่ใช่ไหมแล้วก็อัน
นี้ครูหญิงครูฟ้าอยู่ในท้องคุณแม่เขาบอก
ว่าเวลาที่เราเกิดมาเราคลอดเนี่ยเราจะมี
กระดูกทั้งหมด
350 ชิ้น
เวลาที่เราเกิดมานะ
เป็นเด็กเนี่ยนะเราจะมีกระดูกใช่ไหมมี
กระดูก
นี่นะกระดูกนะคะมีกระดูกเนี่ย
350 ชิ้นแต่พอเราโตขึ้นโตขึ้นโตขึ้น
เนี่ยกระดูกของเราจาก 350 ชิ้นเนี่ยมันจะ
ลดลงแล้วมันก็จะหยุดอยู่เท่านั้นนะพอเรา
โตขึ้นแบบ 100% แล้วครูฟ้าคิดว่าคนเรา
เนี่ยเมื่อโตขึ้นแบบนี้นะคะแบบในรูปนี้
เนี่ยเราจะมีกระดูกทั้งหมดกี่ชิ้น
26 ชิ้น
210 ชิ้นหรือว่า
2099 ชิ้น
คิดว่าข้อไหนคะเนี่ยเราจะมีกระดูกแล้วนับ
ไปเลยนะ 1  2  3  4  5  6  7 เนี่ยกี่
ชิ้นคะครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ขอตอบ
เท่าไหร่คะมีค่ะ
ดี
B
210 ชิ้นใช่ไหมคะมาดูว่าครูฟ้าจะตอบถูก
ไหมทั้งๆๆ
ผิดค่ะ
ทำไม
ก็ผิดแค่นั้นแหละไม่ใช่ 210 ชิ้น
ให้ครูฟ้าตอบอีก 1 ครั้งระหว่าง 26 ชิ้น
กับ 299 ชิ้น
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าข้อไหน
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
26 ชิ้นค่ะ
26 ชิ้นนะคะมาดูว่าครูฟ้าจะถูกหรือว่า
ครูฟ้าจะผิด 2 ครั้งเลยค่ะ
ไม่ถูก
ถูกครั้งที่ 2 ไม่ต้องดีใจมากค่ะ
ตอนที่เราเกิดมานะคะเรามี 350 ชิ้นใช่ไหม
พอเราโตขึ้นโตขึ้นเราก็จะมีเหลือ 26 ชิ้น
นะคะมันไม่ได้หายไปเนาะมันรวมกันมันรวม
กันรวมกันรวมกันเพราะว่าเราโตขึ้นไง
นะคะก็ยังเป็นคำถามเกี่ยวกับกระดูกสมัยใน
ร่างกายของเราเนี่ยนะคะก็จะมีกระดูกที่
ใหญ่ใช่ไหมอาจจะเป็นกระดูกชิ้นใหญ่
กระดูกชิ้นเล็กๆสมัยนี้กระดูกชิ้นเล็กๆ
กระดูกชิ้นใหญ่ๆนะคะคำถามข้อนี้ก็คือถาม
ว่า
กระดูกชิ้นที่
เล็กที่สุดในร่างกายของเรา
อยู่ที่อวัยวะชิ้นไหนอยู่ที่จมูกอยู่ที่
หูหรือว่าอยู่ที่นิ้วมืออันนี้นิ้วมือนะ
นักเรียนข้อนี้นะคะ
อันนี้คือนิ้วมือนะ
โป้งชี้นิ้วกลางนิ้วนางนิ้วก้อย
ครูฟ้าคิดว่ากระดูกชิ้นที่
เล็กที่สุดในร่างกายเราเนี่ยอยู่ที่
อวัยวะชิ้นไหน
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
กระดูกที่เล็กที่สุดในร่างกายของเรา
อาจจะมองไม่เห็นดูค่ะ
อยู่ที่หู
อยู่ที่หูนะคะ
ใช่
โอเคค่ะของมั่นใจนะคะนักเรียนเขาบอกใช่
ค่ะอยู่ที่หูนะคะเรามาดูว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยจะ
ตอบถูกหรือตอบผิดนะคะนักเรียน
ทำๆๆ
[เพลง]
อยู่ตรงไหนคะครูหญิง
ที่เรียกว่า
ทำไมคะครูฟ้าใส่แว่นแล้วครูฟ้าก็มองไม่
เห็นหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้ามองไม่เห็นอะไรเลย
เนี่ยนักเรียนอันนี้นะนักเรียนอาจจะเห็น
นะที่มันเรียกว่า
ผู้หญิงไม่รู้ว่ามันอ่านว่าอะไรนะคะช่าง
มันนะคะแต่ว่ามันคือกระดูกชิ้นนี้นะคะนัก
เรียนที่เป็นกระดูกชิ้นที่เล็กที่สุดที่
อยู่ในหูของเรานะคะมีเล็กแล้วก็ต้องมี
ใหญ่อย่างอาจจะใหญ่ที่สุดใหญ่ในก็ใหญ่ก็
ได้ใหญ่ที่สุดนะคะในร่างกายของเราเนี่ย
อยู่ที่อวัยวะชิ้นไหน
ที่อันนี้อันนี้ก็คือต้นขานะคะตรงนี้นะ
ที่ลูกศรชี้คือต้นขาหรือว่าต้นแขน
มี 2 คือต้นแขนนะคะหรือว่าหน้าแข้ง
ก็จะมีกระดูกกระดูกตรงนี้นะคะนักเรียน
ครูฟ้าคิดว่ากระดูกที่ใหญ่และก็ยาวด้วยนะ
ทั้งใหญ่และยาวนะคะ
อยู่ที่กระดูกอยู่ที่อวัยวะชิ้นไหน
a นะคะต้นขา B ต้นแขนหรือว่า C หน้าแข้ง
ครูฝ้ายคิดว่า
หน้าแข้งค่ะ
หน้าแข้งนะคะ
มาดูว่าครูฟ้าจะตอบผิดไหมไม่ใช่สิครูฟ้า
จะตอบถูกไหมนะคะทั้งๆๆผิดค่ะ
ผิดค่ะ
หรือต้นแขน
ต้นแขนค่ะ
ต้นแขนนะคะทำๆๆผิดค่ะ
ต้นขาค่ะครูฟ้า
ต้นขาหรอ
นี่ไงครูฟ้าก็ดูสิเนี่ยนะคะกระดูกมันมี
ชื่อนะแต่ว่าไม่ต้องมีต้องเรียนเป็นนัก
เรียนอาจจะรู้นะคะผู้หญิงไม่รู้นะคะไม่
ต้องไม่เป็นไรเนาะเนี่ยเห็นไหมกระดูกต้น
ขาเนี่ยชิ้นใหญ่นะคะแล้วก็อย่าเอาใช่ไหม
ยาวที่สุดนิหน้าแข้งหน้าแข้งมันจะเล็ก
กว่าเนาะอาจจะเป็นเพราะว่าต้นขาเราก็ใหญ่
ด้วยนะคะอ่ะ
ต่อไปนะคะคำถามข้อต่อไปเนี่ยเอา Choice
ก่อนแล้วกัน
A
กระดูก
B
กะโหลกเขาเรียกอะไรคะกะโหลกเนาะไม่ใช่
กระโหลก
ใช่ไหมกะโหลกก็คือกระดูกที่
กระดูกตรงนี้ของเราเนาะ
ใช่ไหมกะโหลกนะคะ
แล้วก็
C นะคะ
ฟัน
ฤดู
แล้วก็ฟันนะคะครูฟ้าคิดว่า
อันไหนคือส่วนที่แข็งที่สุดในร่างกายของ
เราแข็งที่แบบว่าอาจจะมีค้อน
ใช่ไหมมีค้อนอย่างนี้ค่ะนักเรียน
มีค้อนแล้วก็ทุกก็ไม่เป็นไรไม่แตกคือมัน
แข็ง
แข็งและแข็งมากๆแข็งที่สุดเพราะว่ากระดูก
ก็แข็ง
กะโหลกก็แข็งฟันก็แข็งแต่อะไรแข็งที่สุด
กระดูก
ฟัน
กระดูกกระโหลกแล้วก็ฟัน
ครูฟ้าขอตอบว่า
ไม่ต้องลุ้นขนาดนั้นนะ
ฟันนะคะ
ถูกก็แถมเดียวนะคะฟันแข็งมากใช่ไหมจริงๆ
แล้วฟันของเรานะคะแข็งกว่ากะโหลกของเรา
เพราะว่ากระดูกของเราเนี่ยก็หากหรือว่า
แต่ได้เนาะแต่ฟันเนี่ยน้อยมากเลยนะ
ที่จะหักหรือว่าแตกนะคะ
ข้อต่อไป
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าในร่างกายของเราเนี่ยนะคะเรา
มีเลือดอันนี้คือเลือดนะคะเลือดเลือด
กรุ๊ป A
Group  B  G  Group  a  b แล้วก็กรุ๊ป O
นะคะในร่างกายของเราเนี่ยมีเลือดประมาณนะ
ประมาณ
กี่ลิตร
แต่ละคนอาจจะไม่เท่ากันนะแต่เอาแบบประมาณ
ๆ
ในร่างกายของเราเนี่ยมีเลือดกี่ลิตรคะครู
ฟ้า
ในร่างกายของเรา Choice คืออะไรคะ
ลืมค่ะขอบคุณนะคะมี A  2 ลิตร
B  5 ลิตรแล้วก็ C  8 ลิตร
B  5 ลิตร C  8 ลิตร
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าในร่างกายของเรามีเลือด
ประมาณกี่ลิตร
ครูฟ้าดื่มน้ำวันละ 2 ลิตร
ค่ะก็แล้วแต่พูดโทรศัพท์
ใช่ค่ะ
ป๊าดื่มน้ำวันละ 2 ลิตรค่ะนักเรียน
คิดว่าเรามีเลือด 2 ลิตรหรอคะในร่างกาย
ของเรามีเลือดประมาณ 2 ลิตร
ครูพลอยคิดว่าในร่างกายของเรา
น่าจะมีเลือดประมาณ
B แล้วกัน
5 ลิตรใช่ไหมคะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
2 ลิตร 5 ลิตรนะคะเป็นคำตอบที่
ถูกค่ะ
ไม่น่าเชื่อนะคะแต่เขาว่าจริงๆแล้วเนาะ
เราจะมีเลื่อนเนี่ยประมาณ 10%
ของน้ำหนักใช่ไหมน้ำหนักของเราน้ำหนักที่
เป็นกิโลกรัมใช่ไหมถ้าครูฟ้าหนัก 60
กิโลกรัมครูฟ้าก็มีเลือดเท่าไหร่
6 ลิตร
ใช่แต่ว่าอันนี้คือ 5 ลิตรเนี่ยอันนี้คือ
ประมาณใช่ไหมถ้าเรามีน้อยกว่านั้นอาจจะ
ไม่ค่อยโอเคมีมากก็ไม่ค่อยโอเคนะคะอ่ะมี
เลือดแล้วไหนๆครูฟ้าก็พูดถึงดื่มน้ำ
แล้วครูฟ้าคิดว่าในร่างกายของเราเนี่ยนะ
คะมีน้ำกี่เปอร์เซ็นต์
30%
60% หรือว่า 90%
น้ำในร่างกายของเราไม่มี 80 แล้วผู้หญิง
ไม่มีค่ะเพราะว่า 80 ไม่ชอบเลข 8 ค่ะชอบ
เลข 9 ชอบเลข 6 แล้วก็ชอบเลข 3 ก็เลยบอก
ว่า 30%  60%
90%
ในร่างกายของเรามีน้ำ
ทำแทน
90%
90% ทำๆๆ
60% ค่ะ
60% ทำๆๆถูกค่ะ
เย้
90% เนี่ยเป็นไปไม่ได้นะคะมันมากเกินไป
อันนี้อันตรายเขาบอกว่าเราจะมีประมาณ 60
ถึง
66% เนาะมันก็อาจจะแล้วแต่นักเรียนก็อาจ
จะได้ยินว่าโอเคมีในร่างกายของเรามีน้ำ
70% อย่างเงี้ยมันก็เป็นเลขประมาณเพราะ
แต่ละคนความสูงน้ำหนักมันไม่เท่ากันนะคะ
แต่ว่าครูฟ้าก็เก่งนะเออก็ถูกหลายๆข้อนะ
คะก็นักเรียนก็คอมเมนต์ปรบมือให้ครูฟ้า
ด้วยเพราะว่าครูฟ้าเก่งดูหน้าแล้วคิดไม่
เก่งแต่เก่งนะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้นะคะเรา
สองคนไปก่อนแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่
วิดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ